le bilan de ce qu'il s'est passé samedi
à Sainte Soline est lourd je le sais j'y
étais
et je l'assume deux manifestants dans le
coma entre la vie et la mort de ton
espèce une sortie sans séquelle grave 47
blessés parmi les forces de l'ordre à
qui nous souhaitons évidemment un prompt
rétablissement de s'en blesser dont
certains mutilés parmi les manifestants
à qui nous souhaitons aussi un pro
rétablissement des violences un
qualifiable ce sont déchaînés et nous
les dénonçons toutes sans ambiguïté mais
c'est votre bilan du week-end monsieur
le ministre vous avez décidé à
Sainte-Soline d'exposer 3000 forces de
l'ordre à la violence dans un champ pour
défendre quoi qu'il en coûte un trou un
trou vide vous avez décidé d'interdire
une manifestation totalement légitime
parce que vous êtes incapable de faire
respecter la loi en matière de partage
de l'eau oui de nombreuses bassines
déclarées illégales sont toujours en
construction et vous êtes incapable
d'assumer votre responsabilité oui la
bassine de sainte Soline mais en danger
la ressource en eau de tout depuis trois
jours vos mensonges ont éclaté au grand
jour des armes de guerre ont bien été
employés samedi des brigades motorisées
étaient bien équipés de LBD des secours
ont été entravés et empêcher
d'intervenir sur hors de l'agendarmerie
des gaz lacrymogènes ont été envoyés sur
des sur des blessés vous mentez comme
vous avez manqué ici lors du fiasco du
Stade de France dans quel pays après
avoir mis deux manifestants dans le coma
toute la chaîne de commandement ne
s'interroge pas sur la méthode de
maintien de l'ordre dans quel pays après
un tel fiasco un ministre peut continuer
de mentir à répétition et petits un
collectif d'opposants politiques
[Musique]